all in favor of prohibiting all future
movies from starting with a giant
eyeball cliche please say aye
or not I did I miss a row of judges
somewhere why is this upside down hang
and dismount so elaborate it doesn't
seem to serve any practical purpose and
there's not a single person around to
impress just slide down the damn rope
lure dead sprint or not did she just run
for like three seconds and then decide
to saunter is that the same artifact we
saw earlier yet it's in a completely
different room then why edit it in
earlier we shouldn't see it till she
does write praised creepy computerized
contraption can't course-correct current
cropped cropped coordinates classic good
to see the robot was at least programmed
with an acute sense of dramatic timing
robot who punches through solid walls
now too weak to out arm Russell Angelina
Jolie seriously I've seen breadsticks
with more girth than her arms there is
no possible way this robot can see this
but editors gotta edit I guess
apparently we were watching this movie
in tutorial mode all this time also this
was training isn't there a way to train
without destroying your entire facility
in your discount iron giant was it
programmed to stop before it took my
head off oh well and that would be a
yeah no someone went to the syndrome
school of testing things you said make
it more challenging are you kidding me
all she had to do was say stop when you
have a safe word it's all the exact same
level of challenging as in not live
rounds again Oh Simon my favorite part
of any installment of the Tomb Raider
video game franchise is the 1980s sitcom
running joke rapport between Laura and
Bryce considering Bryce's ability to
construct an immortal robot his talents
seemed to be wasted in his current
scenario of appealing to the quirks of
people that are stupid rich no one
showers like this except in movies and
Herbal Essence commercials at this point
I'm honestly not sure which this is also
what does a pg-13 shower scene do for
anyone in case you confused it with
Venice Nebraska the first day of the
planetary alignment and we are still no
nearer to discovering the location of
the key the trying to thwart planetary
assignment committee from the latest
James Bond movie was sent to the wrong
set we are working through things based
on ancient cosmological models do you
want t viruses cuz this is how you get T
viruses also it can't be stressed enough
that this is exactly the same character
he plays in Resident Evil extinction
he's the guy who has to find something
impossible for some shady organization
and it's getting blamed because he can't
find it what a weird typecasting
we will have our answer in time for the
relevant planetary alignment Tomb Raider
inspired so many planetary alignment
drinking games that DUI arrests tripled
in the summer of 2001 but I'm happy to
announce that we are almost ready
why is beardless jour as designated book
carrier even here the materials he's
carrying don't seem to be needed and
also aren't acquiring godlike power
meetings usually a fairly closed thing
in fact the sidekick will be so ignored
this entire film he'd be better labeled
as a side stand so we will have
possession of the key in one week one
week even though this time parameter was
never brought up in the entirety of this
every evil person in the world bored me
we have only a single opportunity to
retrieve the two halves of the triangle
and if we hey we must wait another five
thousand years
echoey exposition acquisition egypt
again it's nothing but pyramids and sand
I know gets everywhere in the cracks if
anyone was wondering why the Egyptian
Tourism Board decided not to sponsor
this film I miss you daddy and this
would mark the first time Angelina Jolie
has said those words in regard to Jon
Voight also Richard Croft died exactly
20 years ago to the day of this
planetary alignment on top of that JFK
was released ten years prior to Tomb
Raider and 17 years prior the
Ghostbusters informed us that cats and
dogs will be living together causing
mass hysteria so with all that
information we can conclude that two of
those films are good when is the Eclipse
in one week from today but there is
plenty to look out for until then equip
shadowing the exact alignment of planets
necessary to activate triangle only
occurs once every 5,000 years
listen Lara Croft to blow up and to find
it too bad we didn't get to see any
scenes of teenage Lauren whining about
how she doesn't want to be a worldwide
adventure seeker when she grows up she
just wants to cut hair also dream
splaining well we now know why Laura is
single first off she's an independent
woman who doesn't need a man second she
stabbed her last five boyfriends to
death in their sleep movie will
continually give us unnecessary POV
shots because the thing we all love
about video games is walking through
hallways this movie focuses so much
attention on Laura's breasts I think if
they had just called this movie Laura
Croft twin Raiders no one would have
blinked an eye seems like a pretty
drastic move but since Laura thinks she
hears ticking she's probably feeling a
bit clock blocked we have 82 rooms why
can't you live in the house probably
because it makes the robot orgies he's
obviously been having a little less
awkward for everyone involved this works
also this hammering scene will require
forward cutaways all of which piss me
off
convenient foot propping chair is
convenient two million two hundred
thousand two million three hundred
thousand two million three two million
four hundred thousand ladies paid to
accidentally bidding at auctions is not
only unbinding it's almost impossible
auctioneers are as skilled at
determining bids as Laura Croft is at
Herbal Essence inner showers future
James Bond shows up in a movie that rips
off James Bond maybe we don't maybe we
do why you stole my prayer wheel stole
stole the scene is apparently a battle
of who has the worst accent he read
credits between this and the national
treasure movies Jon Voight has an odd
fascination with playing fathers have
wannabe indiana jones' movie has a clear
policy of no vehicles being allowed to
drive at a normal speed also in the
previous scene Laura rode her motorcycle
to the auction here she's taking her
Aston Martin what makes one trip a
motorcycle trip and another a car trip
she nearly brought photographs it's also
an amazing coincidence the Powell is
going to have the key fall right in his
lap a couple days after being threatened
by the old evil people committee this is
a pleasurable torment my ignorant amuses
me man Fred Powell's dialogue sounds as
if Emily Bronte and f scott Fitzgerald
had a three-way with Aurel Stein unjam
up a jumpring since they clearly have no
issue killing Laura why wouldn't they
have just killed Bryce instead of
locking him up inside his trailer where
does this bullet come from that it only
manages to hit the can and nothing else
on the desk
including Bryce not one of these hookers
has been able to even Nick Laura with a
bullet is this the Dollar General of hit
squats it took Hillary that long to put
on a vest and some slippers
of course Lara is in the exact place is
the phone when you call and at the exact
time you decide to call her because yeah
movies movie establishes the shot of all
the car keys falling down
however Laura still only has two hands
how is she getting every car to go off
at the same time just cut from her
running to her sliding and then another
cut to grabbing the gun from bad guy
then three cups of her getting up off
the slide then about five more cuts of
running and bad guys till she somehow it
gets to a motorcycle hood it's been
confusing to the audience and a little
over the place and there's loud music
bullets firing and she's all jiggly in
her PJ's who will even care cinemasins
cares mother farts cinemasins cares with
time of the essence our protagonist
wastes three seconds doing a full 360
doughnut instead of actually heroic
because reasons is this mess really what
counts is editing in 2001 the shooter is
shooting up to the right yet when we
quick cut to jolie she's also shooting
to the right and later he's still
obviously on the left if you're gonna
give us an epileptic seizure with the
cutting at least have the decency to get
the geography sort of correct why is
this still sitting on the table with
clock pieces around it we've already
seen that she took it to her clock
friend so why wouldn't she have locked
it away afterwards I think gone hero
never misses unless they accidentally
shoot at a friend cliched this editing
ten full seconds a hallway walking with
three different angles seriously I've
seen snapchats from middle schoolers
with more restraint lawyers note I have
never received a snapchat from a middle
schooler UPS driver casually enters a
home without being invited because
apparently what brown can do for you is
invade your privacy and judge your mess
also that concludes the always
compelling people delivering things to
other people's section of the movie with
the bad guys delivering the triangle
piece and now this letter with
absolutely nothing else important
happening by donning dota I knew you
figure this out how he was gonna have a
post deceased letter sent why not just
explain everything there instead of some
random William Blake quote that would
hopefully lead her to ripping up the
first edition text and I miss you and
love you always and forever movie takes
the old letter being read in the voice
of a person who wrote a trope up a notch
by actually showing footage of the
character saying it which makes no sense
because who's he saying it to us
strangest fourth wall break ever by now
I'm sure you would have discovered the
clock I concede it might take a weirdly
specific dream to wake you up in the
middle of the night but by Gauri Olaf
found it it gave its possessive apothem
could be used
good great evil so basically like all
technology then all power can be used
for good or evil
we get it stop Uncle Ben eNOS Hollywood
also I want to point out again how
fucking lucky Richard is that Laura is
both alive and willing to follow in her
father's footsteps
I mean we're resting the fate of the
world on some very specific instances to
happen over the next 20 years
devious dangerous men and women find and
destroy both halves of the trial now
that we are finally finished with this
in-game cutscene can Laura please go on
her mission quest faint Furious 7 could
have gone back a scant 14 years to
realize how stupid an idea it is to put
parachutes on vehicles these binoculars
literally come with a zoom and enhance
cliche built right in we have 72 minutes
to the next alignment we have to work
faster maybe not having your men Hall
Powell's personal couch on this journey
would have shaped off some final minutes
this is not how close the planets are to
each other
also which planets are these even
supposed to be this can't be Earth
because there are only two planets
between Earth and the Sun are those
rings is this supposed to be Saturn
because my very educated mother just
served us noodles and something isn't
quite lining up here's Alex helping pull
down the statue with the rope and here
he is just seconds later routing himself
on from the front are we in the
multiplicity expanded universe now
Laura's overrated
she's good don't get me wrong but she's
in it for the glory whereas I'm in it
for the money
considering Laura clearly doesn't need
money this seems like a bizarre thing to
be bringing up into the belly of the
beast and out of the demons ass
I'll take rejected Taco Bell slogans for
500 Alex Tomb Raider got a head start on
the Jay horror trend that would begin in
2002 by adding some ghost girls to these
ancient ruins why the fuck is this
little ghost girl helping Laura does she
know Laura's a good person why would
anyone help Laura when the triangles
supposed to be hidden from humans
forever
what is this glow stick for she planning
on starting a rave because this room is
already helot to receive the gift of
heaven mind you they probably can't hear
you down below but why transit we have
two minutes mr. West you'll the Tomb
Raider figure it out
so we're just going with Tomb Raider as
a legitimate thing you would call a
person why not archaeologist or simply
you're the expert mr. West
Tempus Fugit yes time flies thanks for
the translation Laura I'm not sure why
man for it felt the need to speak in
Latin all of a sudden he placed the
clock here at the exact moment of a lion
attack I'm confused why did the
Illuminati go through the trouble of
burying the triangle on two ends of the
earth but still give people the chance
to dig it up later also
under these rules how is anyone supposed
to figure out the exact alignment when
they're deep down inside this room back
in the day that these ancient people
live there was no way of knowing the
exact time without looking at the Sun or
stars or something how do you see those
things from here also also five thousand
years ago they could not have known that
airplanes would exist and that getting
the two ends of the earth within a week
would be possible and we find out later
this time-travel thing only goes into
the past forty one forty Alec stops
counting at thirty two and after a
minute of conversation he then starts
off at twelve eleven yeah sounds about
right Laura definitely missed her chance
to jump on this log in time but the
movie lies to us and tells us she made
the jump successfully also what a ripoff
the people of light rigged this book so
that people who were smart enough could
get the triangle but apparently you have
to do a lot of the work yourself
Manfred sees the CGI stone man throwing
the sword at this distance and can
easily dodge it but to science I'm a bad
guy I'll use one of my employees as a
human shield instead Elle he even does
this very thing the next time one of
them throws a sim car at him also how
exactly were these very slow
uncoordinated bunched into one corner
bad guys supposed to kill anyone you
could simply just run away from the
Frank Powell's many years of training
and defensive tactics against
resurrected God statues it's finally
paid off why is this statue polished
here and not killing her all right
because this movie is Indiana Jones and
to ripoff another classic scene got it
well I surely didn't think this would be
necessary I was just hanging back and
watching my ancient magic stone men get
destroyed and figured at least one of
them would be able to kill you guys
guess not we interrupt this obvious boss
battle to remind Hollywood that just
because the property is based on a video
game doesn't mean you have to have video
game mechanics you're making a movie now
moving it up already there's so much
whatever going on here that I'm just
gonna add 20 cents for smashing seams
I'm level pegging with mr. pal
oh man level pegging is so hard to do
also do you happen to have footage I can
study in 66 hours and 53 minutes of
spike movies imperative time crunch
message we have time for scenes like
powell getting massaged or laura Horning
up a bunch of Cambodian monks your
father said you will never give up knew
my father
that's coincidental as hell sure but how
did he know this was Richard Crofts
daughter since even if he met her it
would have been over 20 years ago
by the way I know her dad told her as a
kid to find this triangle of power thing
and so she thinks she needs to find it
just from a pure curiosity standpoint I
can see why you'd want it but unless
she's planning on traveling through time
which is what this triangle apparently
lets you do why would she
the sky she could technically win this
movie by flying to Wolverines cabin in
Canada and hiding out until the
planetary alignment is over you always
be Illuminati it's no such thing
anyway now see Lara seems to be of the
belief that if someone tells you
something isn't true then you just throw
a knife to make it true
conveniently placed decorative railing
thankfully prevents us from seeing Alex
West's double O seven inches Wow
time to save universe again then is it
considering we've never seen them save
the universe once this seems more like
dialogue for a sequel than an initial
outing it bums going to sleep again
down the left cheek really fascinating
to be fair no less fascinating than the
majority of this movie no seriously are
you confusing Siberia with any other
foreign country Siberia is as synonymous
with Russia as election meddling or
collusion
welcome to the dead Sam if Christopher
Walken popped up right now I'd take off
at least five sins they've traveled
across the world to find a slightly more
advanced airport security scanner it's a
Time storm time is broken here and you
know this how exactly did you go to Time
storm school are you an official time
meteorologist now fifty bucks says the
pieces inside the Sun Alex decides to
play the game of who's got the bigger
Raider so the Illuminati really wanted
some asshole to jump around on this
structure and go through all this bullsh
just to use the key I'm still really
unclear as to why they made it possible
to find the thing they didn't want found
but then putting people through this
convoluted nonsense just so we're clear
due to their slightly different orbital
planes the planets lining up in three
dimensions like this is astronomically
impossible well someone please remind me
exactly why mrs. Bob Thornton cares
about this guy again all you've seen in
the movie is animosity and accusation
yet now she's all in trying to save him
considering no electronics work here
because it's a dead zone what kind of
voodoo magic is in this laser sight that
allows it to work you
how does she know how to do any of this
it's not like this has ever been done
before
you can't just Google a walkthrough and
some cheat codes in real life but in the
unholy cuz this you could have written
in your gems he most definitely could
have but instead chose to leave weird
quotes from poems and hope you would
somehow figure out how to do all this
why can't we use just this once
we can't change time bullsh
we know she's gonna use it to save Alex
so she could absolutely use it to save
you while you're at it maybe you can go
back and keep Michael Bay from the
Transformers franchise priorities void
priorities miss destroy the tribe in the
letter you gave Lauren why didn't you
just tell her to destroy the clock game
over nobody ever gets the triangle
without the clock so why go through all
this this is one of the most unthought
out endings to a movie ever made a
minute does she have control of how much
time she can go back is she doing this
with her mind how the fuck does this
time-travel thing even work if this is a
matter of strength I'm pretty sure you
can exact the same amount of force with
a flat palm against the flat side of the
blade but hey if you'd rather Rob Roy
yet and slice up your palms you do you
boo
look if this knife still has all its
forward momentum to the point that it's
shaking in midair then I don't know how
turning it around is gonna make it fly
in another direction it should just fall
into the ground right he's seen
particularly concerned that I shouldn't
take this so was pal been holding this
watch back in his bag of tricks to use
just in case he gets stabbed and left
for dead by Laura alright no he's coming
down get the motivator you just hurry
yeah speaking of hurrying in the time
that it took you to have this
conversation she could have run down
grab the watch and already been out but
by all means please converse slowly in
the disintegrating tomb you've been
rated look no matter what this movie
says this dudes been doing nothing that
would make us think he's a badass we've
seen him meditating getting massages
sitting down while others do work and
absolutely zero ab crunches so fuck off
Tomb Raider has the audacity to spoil
who actually did indeed let the dogs out
oh my god thank Christ the Tomb Raider
finally addressed the notion that Laura
never wears a dress because I would have
just left the movie pissed off that
there was no resolution to this
storyline to be the guy that has never
been able to top Conair
the fate of billions will depend upon
you but she's in it for the glory
whereas I'm in it for the money he's in
it for the money not science mr. Powell
your explanation for this is I propose
that we end the world the names bond
James Bond
it's adventure time
[Music]